What the government can't tolerate is basically having large denomination notes on steroids.
It can't allow people to make large transactions easily, across borders-
I think we need to worry about the privacy of those of us who use hundred dollar bills and bitcoin.
It's not right to assume that we're all criminals
and therefore need to have these things taken away from us.
What the Federal Reserve and other central banks do is reverse money laundering.
Money laundering takes dirty money and makes it clean,
they take clean money and it ends up being dirty.
So when banking services are shut off for people who are doing legal and harmless business.
Cash is a badge of freedom.